sorry
whatever
it is weird staring at you for
that long electric man a sound man
there's a dinosaur man there's an
octopus man and then there's this old man
there's nothing
spidey what
the avengers what's that i love
sure
that saved me mj
okay
you've been rolling this off
just me
here buddy let me help you here
it's okay should we do the kiss
Welcome back everyone marvel just released a
whole bunch of spider-man no way home deleted
scenes and bloopers so we'll break them all
down they shot rows and rows of hard drives
more footage than they actually needed for the
film they could have turned this into a six
hour movie and we would have sat there
and watched every single minute of it
we're doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
because moon knight is starting next week i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes located for all
the other disney plus series all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the movie on the video
there's so much to cover that i'll just start with
the good stuff toby maguire andrew garfield and
venom and some matt murdock daredevil too there's
not a ton of venom in here because i think that
his scenes were cut earlier in production than
the other versions of spider-man originally venom
would have been there for the final boss fight
at the statue of liberty they'd always plan on
having five of the sinister six villains there
dr octopus was always going to turn good midway
through the fight because of peter's special chip
that he made in his stolen star tech fabricator
but all the other villains that you saw would have
acted the same green goblin electro sandman lizard
the difference was that venom would have
actually shown up in the fight and been
the sixth sinister six character making it
a true sinister six for a brief hot second
except he would have had a similar arc to doctor
octopus he starts out fighting all the different
versions of spider-man tom holland andrew garfield
toby maguire then he realizes that they're the
good ones and starts helping them because that's
his whole thing he tries to be good despite the
urges of his venom symbiote to eat human brains
for that special chemical that symbiotes need to
survive they didn't really get into that during
tobey maguire's spider-man 3. maybe i should go
to new york and speak to this uh spider-man so the
post-credits scene with venom would have happened
in a different place he would have entered the
movie sooner and when he says maybe we should go
to new york and talk with this peter parker then
disappears thanks to dr strange's second spell
because this was happening way earlier he would
have actually made his way to new york city and
they would have paid that name drop off in a big
way but what ended up happening is that they got
to the point where everyone they had wanted had
signed on to the movie including toby mcguire
and andrew garfield and they switched the release
order of the marvel phase 4 movies spider man no
way home was originally coming out after doctor
strange too that led to some big changes in both
movies i'll talk more about the doctor strange
changes during my doctor strange 2 trailer videos
but once the mains had signed on in the sinister
six villains they decided that they didn't need
the extra juice from having venom there in the
final fight and they could save that for future
movie and just make him a smaller post-credit
scene they'd always planned on including venom in
some way but they weren't exactly sure how that
was going to happen that's what they told to the
venom people that were producing that movie that
made that post-credit scene with tom holland in it
otherwise they wouldn't have been able to do
that before they did spider man no way home
that's what happened with a lot of the cameos
that they had planned for spider-man no way home
they developed several contingency plans just in
case one of the actors didn't sign their contracts
so they had a couple alternate versions of
this big final fight at the statue of liberty
with different groups of characters some of them
wildly different than the one that you saw during
the movie like early on there was a version
where mysterio came back before they knew that
toby maguire and andrew garfield would come back
they explained that it was willian guinta reva
using mysterio's techies stolen at the end of
spider-man far from home he's still out there
by the way even though they teased that mysterio
might have faked his death they were playing it
as if he had died and then soldered the earth
for peter behind him by doxing him and dragging
his name through the mud that was meant to set up
peter's big choice during the film the big spell
two big spells that is they had a bunch of extra
scenes of tobey maguire and andrew garfield
together by themselves and also when they met
tom holland's mcu spider-man for the first time
part of it was them just having fun with the two
of them just a lot of funny moments as you can
see here but part of when they were meeting all
three of them for the first time on screen was the
writers wanting to get it right so that it didn't
feel too comedic or feel as if it wasn't one of
the biggest cinematic events in recent history
there's this fine line that spider-man movies draw
between comedy and heart so a lot of the funny
moments just had to hit the cutting room floor
between the two of them toby maguire and andrew
garfield because a lot of them are just ad-libs
with them showing up on the day and just having
fun with each other like the whole thing with
the pointing meme like everybody just broke
down laughing when they saw they actually did
the pointing meme the iconic pointing meme was
actually andrew garfield's idea to begin with
and it started right before they shot their
first actual scene in the movie together
they were walking onto set in all their costumes
and he said it just came to him as a random idea
like hey let's do this meme with the pointing
and it was mostly the three of them trying not
to stare at each other's crotches according to
andrew garfield for those of you also asking
about the fake butt tom holland was the one
who claims that one of the spider-man butts on
set was not a real butt tom holland did recently
say that one of you guys wore a fake butt on set
so i need to know i heard this who had the fake
butt andrew well i have no idea it's not not me
so i have no clue i don't want to like i don't
want to i don't know i assumed everyone's butts
were their butts so it's not you it's not tom so
i guess no i don't think it's totally i've seen
toby's but toby's got back my assumption based
on andrew garfield denying it like he laughed
and denied it would be that it was tobey maguire
he is the more mature spider-man of the three of
them you wouldn't think it at first glance but
that is something that the costume department
thinks about when they're designing spider-man
suits but apparently everything does not get tuned
up in post-production like you can't fix every
single little thing one of the bigger deleted
scenes also includes matt murdock daredevil and
happy hogan you see daredevil actually defending
happy hogan as his very good lawyer you're gonna
need a really good lawyer in the movie he tells
peter that he's cleared of all the charges
but happy is still in trouble for stealing
the stark tech fabricator in the iron man mark
vi reactor so he has to get a very good lawyer
and they filmed a bunch of extra scenes where john
favreau talks about having a foggy memory because
during the ben affleck daredevil movie he played
a version of foggy nelson details you owe me that
her name's elektra nachos well she
sounds like a mexican appetizer
it's greek genius my father's nicholas nachos
the billionaire later you can see he and charlie
cox getting grilled by the damage control lawyers
and it's just more of him being happy's very
good lawyer the little girl who played iron man's
daughter in avengers end game lexi robbie morgan
stark she also filmed a scene for the movie that
was cut i'm assuming it also came during this
montage when they're all getting raked over the
coals and she was just speaking on the behalf of
peter and happy hogan for those of you wondering
why pepper potts never got involved i feel like
she could have stepped in at any time and said
don't press charges on either of them because
technically she owned all the stuff that happy
stole the way gwyneth paltrow explains that she's
always game to come back if robert downey jr comes
back and i think the question of him coming back
is just them finding the right story for him to
come back during i do not think it's going to be
during doctor strange too i think it'll probably
be like avengers secret wars or something later
down the line i still think the version of iron
man that we see in doctor strange 2 is a variant
that's played by some different actor i've already
talked about the alternate post credit scenes
they did for toby maguire and andrew garfield
in my other deleted scenes videos and as you
can see they shot a bunch of extra footage with
the sinister six villains together just walking
around town like a casual group of high-tech super
villains and for those of you hoping that they'll
make amazing spider-man 3 at some point they keep
teasing fans with amazing spider-man 3 they called
andrew garfield peter number 3 during the lineup
at the end and for his special features they
used the special amazing spider-man movie font to
create an amazing spider-man number 3 featurette
for him about how amazing it was that he came back
does it not feel that they're teasing us with
amazing spider-man 3 like wouldn't be cool if we
actually made this my assumption right now though
is that what they'll do is they'll tell the story
of amazing spider-man 3 over the course of a
couple other movies like they did for the hulk
during the avengers movies because they couldn't
make a hulk solo movie before instead of straight
up making amazing spider-man 3 as a solo movie
like we'll get that story but it'll be inside
a couple other people's movies in the future if
there are any big easter eggs that you spotted
that i didn't talk about during the video or my
other deleted scenes videos just write them below
in the comments my full moon knight episodes will
start next week after they start releasing them
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss any of those congratulations marvin
martinez you're the giveaway winner from my
last big marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for more spider man no
way home deleted scenes and click here for my
new moon knight trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!